I'm gonna consider this a teachable
moment Studios out there except Fox
apparently you're the ones who do it
right if there is a comic book character
that lends itself to rated our content
if you make the movie rated R we will
watch it like why not do that for venom
I mean why
[Music]
and so venom is a film adaptation of the
character venom you remember him from
the comic books you kind of remember him
from I guess he was in spider-man 3
anyhow this is the standalone venom film
Eddie Brock is played by Tom Hardy we're
gonna get the venom we were kind of in
this venom movie there's this super
shady sciency corporation that's
harvesting these symbiotes from space
one finds its way to Eddie Brock so
Eddie Brock becomes the antihero venom
who needs to figure it out and take on
super evil science guy first of all what
I liked about the movie what I liked
most is the Eddie Brock venom dialogue
and dynamic that dynamic is awesome Tom
Hardy can hear venom talk to him in his
mind but no one else can hear him they
kind of reminded me of inner space when
tuck Pendelton would talk to Jack Potter
that lends itself to some funny moments
some humorous moments some otherwise
enjoyable moments because you hear what
the Venom symbiote is thinking or at
least saying to him well Tom Hardy's
trying to keep a straight face and talk
to someone else
it's a neat dynamic to hear the wants
urges and needs of this alien thing and
whether or not Tom Hardy's gonna go
along with it or possibly not point is
whether or not the dialogue was cheesy
serious humorous sarcastic
I enjoyed that in the movie and when
venom came out to play when the whole
symbiote takes him over and he becomes
venom gosh it was damn entertaining
could have been more entertaining if the
movie was rated R I'll get to that in a
second but those things basically had
what I wanted to see in a venom movie
grande doesn't shoot webs out of his
fists figured he wouldn't but that's
missing but generally speaking I do wish
venom Eddie Brock and their dynamic was
in a better movie and overall better
movie that's more interesting maybe has
a stronger villain look this movie is
starting out hamstrung because the venom
story the origin and the comic books he
is interesting starts out on spider-man
rips him off he rejects him then he goes
on to Eddie Brock they both have an axe
to grind against spider-man he becomes
an antihero who kills people spider-man
doesn't like that but he's not
necessarily evil and it gets even more
interesting when that hero and that
antihero have to team up to fight a
greater evil this movie does not have
spider-man nor can it so it just it has
to make its own story up to say that I
didn't care about the super evil science
corporation or the guy who runs it would
probably be an understatement
I didn't care about this science he not
Oscorp corporation I didn't care about
the dude running it he was the most
boring villain ever if he's trying to be
a snarky businessman I didn't find him
interesting if he's trying to be a loud
angry villain I didn't find him
threatening if he's trying to be stoic
and evil I didn't find him menacing the
dude was just boring as hell my
knee-jerk reactions to say he was
miscast but no I think you
terribly written I didn't care about
Eddie Brock's relationship with his ex
Tom Hardy and Michelle Williams no
chemistry here just wasn't feeling it
and could this movie have benefited from
being rated R absolutely think it
could've at first I thought it was film
to be rated R but then did the thing
where they just like cut away when he's
gonna bite a head off venom kills like a
grand total of three people in this
movie is usually bite the head off but
they cut away and then he throws this
really shadowy body you don't see any
blood whatsoever not even shadows of
blood spurts there's just nothing I was
like all right they made edits to cut it
down but then there's this one scene
where he takes on a bunch of SWAT team
members and I was like well not how do
you do that pg-13 or rated-r venom
couldn't kill the SWAT team members or
just good cops doing their jobs they're
not crooked or anything like that if
this movie was rated R you could have
had crooked cops there could have had a
bunch of douche bags under the payroll
of super stupid science E corporation
and venom could have just slaughterhouse
- all of them even the scene in his
apartment that first time he's not full
venom but the Venom symbiote it's like
taking these dudes out he's protecting
him you see it in the trailer that scene
is awesome but if it was rated R you
could have killed more folks at least
had more compound fractures and it was a
violent story he's a violent character
as part of the intrigue of venomous
someone who's so violent is actually not
a bad guy and you got to see that
violence in front of your face otherwise
you don't feel that dynamic or conflict
if they aren't out all the bugs I want
to see a sequel for this movie but
that's whether or not it makes enough
money to have it I had heard and in
retrospect and then making this [ __ ] up
I feel like I'm not I heard this movie
was gonna kind of play like a horror
movie like it was gonna have horror
elements to it which totally made sense
to me this thing's taken over this guy's
body making him move and do things he
otherwise wouldn't do but he's totally
conscious for it but I didn't see that
it doesn't play like horror to me just
kind of plays like comic-book action
movie guys in the end venom it's not as
bad as I heard it was there's also not
as good as we wanted it to be Tom Hardy
and venom that dynamic is the best part
of the movie by far every scene without
Tom Hardy and venimos like get back to
it man the movies not a total wash there
is enjoyment in it that is to say it's a
pretty fun time if you're drunk yeah now
it's a party often do you drink so you
can get through the boring scenes get
back to venom its medicinal at that
point and in true Sony spider-verse
fashion I guess spider-man's not in his
Universal this isn't really spider-verse
but in true you know what I mean there's
a lot of us out there predicted they
show the last shot if not last scene of
the movie in the trailer why do they do
that
stop doing that Sony right so venom have
seeing it what did you think about it
whatever you thought comment below let
me know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]